you know he's my family and I wanted to
be by its family as well Anderson Cooper
and Benjamin Massoni may not be a couple
anymore but Anderson's ex will play a
major part in his newborn son's life on
Monday the TV journalist appeared on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert and
revealed Benjamin will serve as a
co-parent to their baby boy Wyatt my
former partner Benjamin is going to be a
co-parent 2 to 2 Wyatt even though we're
not together anymore but you know he's
my family and I wanted to be quiet
family as well and get this the 47 year
old nightclub owner was in the delivery
room with Anderson and the surrogate
when Wyatt was born he was he was 7.2
pounds at birth and he is sweet and soft
and healthy and I am beyond happy
despite some reports that the two were
back on a source told et that's not the
case
Anderson and Benjamin split in March
2018 after going public with their
relationship in 2015 at the time
Anderson told ET in a statement quote
Benjamin and I separated as boyfriends
sometime ago we are still family to each
other and love each other very much the
news anchor first announced that he was
a dad on Thursday on his CNN show
Anderson Cooper 360 on Monday I became a
father never actually said that before
out loud and it still kind of astonishes
me and on Monday he couldn't help but
gush about his little one it's
extraordinary
I mean it's this guy it's astonishing
it's like I just stared him and hold him
and like I just can't believe like a
that he's gonna depend on me and that he
belongs
you know and that he's here and it's
just astonishing it's I just never
dreams I mean I've always dreamed about
it but I never thought I would actually
be able to do it and it's just been
incredible and if all that wasn't cute
enough get this Anderson said that his
longtime pal Andy Cohen and Andy's
one-year-old son Benjamin are helping
Wyatt out in
a big way my son is entirely wearing
hand-me-downs from Andy Cohen's son okay
hey I'm inherently cheap I like of sure
I like a good value I wanted my son to
be like a depression-era child who like
grows up wearing hand-me-down clothes
and turns out clothes aren't the only
thing Wyatt and Benjamin are sharing the
moment anderson announced it I got bunch
of DMS from Eagle iord radio and E
listeners saying wait is that where your
nanny went is that where your nanny went
yep on Mondays radio and E the Bravo
star revealed that they're even sharing
the caretaker
we had long planned this transition and
she is now with Anderson and I know
she's gonna get Wyatt on a great sleep
schedule just like she got Ben and I'm
so happy for Anderson Andy and Anderson
are truly the besties we need right now
and Wyatt
Benjamin here's to you carrying on that
BFF legacy despite being one of the most
respected names in news here's what Andy
told et in 2016
about his pal AC I think that what what
might surprise you about Anderson is how
silly he is or can be and how easily
bored he is he and I text each other
often me from the Bravo Clubhouse he
from CNN headquarters and we say I'm so
bored our bar for entertainment is very
high